[Music]
this is entertainment tonight is the
voice trying to shoot down the new
American Idol before can even get off
the ground
hi everybody and welcome camera Madsen
is here with me tonight and I guess all
is fair in love war and singing
competitions because the voice is
playing for kids no doubt about that
because they have signed on to of idols
all-time greatest contestants I'm going
to make the big announcement right now
ladies and gentlemen meet one of the
coaches for season 14 next spring of The
Voice what's going on Blake hey I'm
[ __ ] your cup and I can join your
show I know my gun stop getting pregnant
every five minutes please I can't wait
to beat you it's gonna be so glorious
Kelly's surprise announcement has a lot
of folks wondering is the voice out to
crush American Idol before it's come
back after all we know Idol producers
were interested in getting Clarkson to
join the show when it comes to ABC next
year Kelly's voice announcement came one
day after another Idol favorite Jennifer
Hudson announced she'll joined the voice
in the fall Hudson was the winning coach
on the UK version of the voice earlier
this year
[Applause]
so where to Simon stand on all of this
while the former Idol judge got in a
laugh at his old show's expense I always
thought if they could get Kelly he would
be a big deal
somebody just told me she's doing the
voice and then I thought what about
Jennifer Hudson no she's doing the
voices so I thought William Hung I think
he'd be a great joke former Idol judge
Harry Connick jr. was shocked when we
told him that Clarkson was joining rival
show Boys Express I'm hearing it you
know she's amazing and she's like the
perfect person to judge a show like that
because she knows from both sides what
it's like to have hits and what it's
like to be in a competition so she's
gonna be amazing
all right so just be clear Kelley will
be on the voice in the spring of next
year Jennifer will be on next season
which starts this fall
[Music]
you